okay what up guys welcome to the just
pearly things youtube channel today i
have two special guests on the show
and welcome to episode i forgot one of
the pre-games
uh before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification bell the way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos and
subscribe to the channel because every
wednesday thursday and saturday i do a
live show and um
yeah and you if you turn on
notifications and you'll be notified
every time i'm live so that's chill
on top of that okay
um we have a sponsor today it's cooking
with chris guys i'm down 12 pounds on
this meal plan
look
thank you
but for real like what happens is you
basically it's expensive i'm gonna tell
you guys that okay it's not cheap but
what you do is you tell them foods you
already like eating and he makes a
custom-made meal plan for you and the
other cool thing is he calculates all
the nutrients that you need in a day so
a lot of people when they're trying to
lose weight they're super hungry because
they're they're just eating less shitty
food like they're doing it they're in a
calorie deficit but they're still not
getting the nutrients they need so he
calculates all of that for you and like
literally guys this is the best i've
ever played volleyball in my life i went
from going like 11 12 kills a game i got
22 in my last game like this is the best
volleyball i've ever played in my life
they put me in back row i've never
played back row before
um
okay but seriously get the meal plan the
link is in the description
um and on top of that if you guys want
if you have any comments that you want
me to pay attention to or read super
chat them and i will read them and
lastly
let me know if the mic audio is okay
i've been having issues lately so if
there's if they're too loud too soft
anything like put it in the chat because
that way i know
okay
so
why don't you guys start bye
so today you guys were talking about
leah thomas and i decided to bring in
two college athletes because who is more
qualified than
women in sports um so why don't you guys
say your name your age where you're from
and what sport you play
my name is amani i'm 22 years old i'm
from south london croydon the ends you
know
and i play basketball
um i'm jessica i am 27 years old and i'm
from california and i play basketball as
well
and i'm
pearl if you didn't know i'm 25 and i
play volleyball and basketball sometimes
but not not as much
okay so today we're talking about the
news
that leah leah thomas i believe her name
is has
shattered
the women's swimming record in mcaa
division one
now this would be really cool okay
except you find out that this is a trans
a trans woman so she was a man about a
year before
she took hormone replacement for a year
she was ranked 450th among men
and then joins the women women's league
and she breaks the record
for for some some swim thing
um
i wanted to see what you guys take is on
this
do you think it's fair
do you want to go for a sir
um
it's a controversial topic so
um
it's like
a part of me is like
we want everyone to like everyone to be
equal so if she wants to come out as a
woman like she has the right to come out
as a woman but
does that mean she has a right
to compete in a woman's sport when she's
got more testosterone levels than normal
women do and she's probably not
like she's not fully a woman yet because
her hormone replaceable replacement has
only been done for a year so i don't
know how long it takes for you to
like fully be
a woman if that makes sense um
and compete as a woman well i'm just
like i'm not
a part of me is like it's not fair like
she's competing in a women's league
when she was like a man just a year ago
but
a part of me is like shouldn't we start
like allowing this kind of things to
happen i don't know
it's tough it's tough because like we
were talking earlier i would be i would
be upset just imagine if we've been
practicing all season
going undefeated and it comes to the
final game and we're playing against
their starting five has
two
two or three
trans women on it it's just like
we're about to get bodied because
they're
like we've talked about they're just
scientifically just stronger than us and
so it's even it's like
harder to compete with them if we're
already
at a deficit
and so it's it's hard because you want
to respect somebody decision for
their choice in life
there's also on the other hand is like
just because you
take hormones and your hormone level is
this
does that it's like does it fully
qualify you as a woman because there's
so much more to
being a woman
and
it's it's just
it's like heartbreaking yeah because in
the states like we said four years of uh
college you're training and if you are
in the limelight like oh this year i'm
uh i'm gonna go to the ncaa finals and i
know i'm gonna swim my best and i know
that i'm a shoe-in to be first place
and then you have someone who a year ago
was a man testosterone levels are still
and i don't know where
her levels are right now but they're
still
higher than a regular woman and they
just come in and
they destroy everything if personally if
i was a man and i was trash at one sport
and i'm not saying this is what trans
women do but if i was trash i once were
it's a cheat code honestly it'd be like
because no one no one questions like oh
like if you say i identify as a woman on
nowadays no one questions it it's just
like okay that's what you want to
respect you and then essentially i
understand
but it's like as a cheat code like oh
i'm going dominating this and get a
full-ride scholarship to college get
this go play pro this that the third and
it's it's just
it sucks in the sense because it's like
we
we we can't
we can identify as a man but we won't
stand a chance in men's leagues like we
can't do the same thing that oh
like if a man becomes a woman and they
start going into women's leagues like
they'll rank through the
through the like rankings but if we do
that
like we could be good but we're not
gonna be like anywhere near as good as
like
yeah yeah
and i i always wonder like
do men
do men like care as much when women
transition into
uh
being a man when it's like oh they're a
trans man
and i often wonder like
do they even like think about that
because
i don't want to say there's not
as much in being a man but there's a lot
but
there's more into being a woman i always
wonder that but yeah well we're not
gonna take away opportunity from them
yeah where when the men the men join our
like if we if i transitioned tomorrow
did a hormone replacement for a year
like i'm not gonna do [ __ ] to a guy
i'm six foot like it's not even that
tall in basketball you're right it's not
even that tall in women's basketball
again men's i get my ass beat
um but
they they come into arlington they take
away the opportunities that we work
so hard like like women
i can't even think of like a harder
working group of people like people in
women's sports we get like no money yeah
we
ask money and we work so hard for the
little opportunity and like moments that
we get yeah and then
like these guys just come in and i know
they're like transitioned or whatever
but you still were a dude for 24 years
yeah or 22. like yeah you don't think
that effects has any effect on your body
it has it has a huge effect i
and i don't i don't know like science
behind it but i feel like there should
be a
there should be a
time limit you're making this decision
it's like it's like if someone
transferred from one school to another
they put you through a um probation
period to where you cannot play at the
school that you're at because of your
transitioning from one school to another
and so i feel like there should be a
probation period like yeah it sucks but
we want to be fair for everybody
i don't think we should let him in at
all
you can't switch bone density wrist
strength
like
like it's not just testosterone it's
like our bone structure is a day like
look at it like let's just i'm gonna
just i'm just gonna pull up
taking uh hormones like
change it does it change your muscles as
well i may be ignorant asking this
question i don't know i just like look
it
i just like i don't need a science
degree to look at this picture and say
this isn't fair
like i don't have shoulders
i
like i i i'm looking at this picture
okay i can't even think of like what
this
this former dude can take to make this
fair he's just never gonna look like
yeah it's
like can you i can't think of anything
no
is it hot
oh is it no isn't it like
i know i don't know how transitioning
works but like when
do you when are you fully like
identified as a woman is when
is whenever you
you don't have you don't even have to
take
hormones to identify
physiologically like when are you more
of a woman than a man when you're when
you trans never
come on never
no there is a
not i won't
can you have a period
can you burn your child partially
is that you're a uterus
yeah
that it's like it's like okay if i dress
up like an octopus does that make me an
octopus no i said that so a funny thing
funny thing yesterday i was going to
mcdonald's and i was saying then in the
drive-through and i told my friend i was
like identify as a car like what are
they going to say like no you can't like
no you can't come through it but i if i
identified as that like
yeah that's where like
like the line is between
like
like
society today it's like you can kind of
just do it like it's good because we
have a lot of freedom we can do whatever
we want to like if i if today i just
feel like i don't want to be a girl
anymore which
god forbid
but um
if i don't i have the right to do that
which is like completely crazy yeah it's
crazy but
it is like
like i like the fact that societies like
this like we have a lot of freedom and
stuff yeah but
it is hard when like stuff like this
happens especially as an athlete myself
we
we do work hard trust me yes we
sometimes we have to get part-time jobs
whilst we're still yeah
athletes because we don't even get paid
enough like yeah
it's like someone else can just
like steal all of that away from you in
the blink of an eye yeah
can you i can't even imagine working my
whole damn life because
i don't know because when i was 18 was
when like the trans stuff kind of first
started that was when the caitlyn jenner
like yeah like that was when it went on
the national like forefront it was when
caitlyn jenner
like that was like a cultural moment
right
and
it's kind of sad because i see the
repercussions of people like letting
people live in delusion today
because by not by like saying you were
you're an actual woman and having that
conversation and like
i in my opinion i feel like it's like
common sense to just know like you're
never gonna actually be a woman you can
dress like a woman look at them but you
can't carry children yeah that's true
and
like i feel like by letting that
delusion go now we see the consequences
later
because people didn't say anything then
and they just kept letting it go and
letting it go and now like
girls like the girls now today have to
like suffer for it yeah i i can
understand that completely yeah i just
thought about something so
you know how in the olympics they have
two separate uh
two separate olympics they have the
regular olympics and the paralympics
there
probably should be
a league or whatever for people who do
transition to be able to play with other
people that are transitioning
because it would be fair across the
board
everybody will be they may be
transitioning at different times but
everybody will have before been a man so
they're playing against people who are
just like them
instead of
playing against
women that are like physiological yeah
a biological woman yeah
no i i would support a league like that
yeah i would be all gung-ho for it i
don't think anyone would really watch it
but yeah i mean you could have trans
women out there duncan something yes
it might be interesting
it would just be like it
would just be like
[Applause]
like what you think i mean i definitely
want to see something it'd be
interesting
interesting you see oh my gosh you see
the mix relay
um
no i'm gonna show this to you guys
on the screen
sorry chat i don't know how to do it yet
um i'm trying to say the mixed like uh
a track relay yeah mix
oh so they have like a woman running
yeah and like the dudes just like blow
the girls out of the freaking water like
look at this
look at this the girls are like i'm
gonna turn off the sound
girls are like going yeah i've ran this
relay before in uh high school
chillin and it's like if a female is
behind look at she's ahead of everyone
now look at watch these guys just smoke
her
and
i don't know why
they had
why that team had the um
is that the girl is that an anchor
position no that
that might be yeah boom
gone
yeah i don't know if that's a
she's trying so hard too
no i think that's the third leg
i don't know what it is it's just shows
like they're just the only point is that
she's in first and all these guys are
gonna like lap her
and it's interesting as to
why they chose that order because i
think they can
choose
no it was an anchor
oh why why would they have her last i
think there so i can i can kind of
understand it they probably set it up to
where they have
the two
the two men running against the other
women
to end
and then
actually they had one man running
against one woman and then the other man
ran against men and then the woman ran
against women and then tried to
offset it
she did a good job though because she
stood her ground kind of it was because
uh she did she did but there was a
lead yeah yeah she did
she did such a good job but like he was
what else could she do you could have a
hundred you could have a 100 meter lead
thank yeah it's true though like that's
that's just the reality that we all have
to face yeah men
biologically are stronger they're more
like they have
the ability to be more athletic than us
and
yeah that's the that's the reality of
growing up that's a reality that took me
hard because i wanted to be better than
all the guys yeah same yeah
well and even like i was telling the
girl that was here last time the
olympian girl
um
no but like like she's probably better
than a lot of guys
but if she goes up against the lions
team i put money on the bun
it depends on who she goes up against
yeah i feel like it depends yeah i would
honestly put money
on
pretty much all the guys
like because i just no offense to the
london lions team they're good they're
they're so they're so oh my god they're
the best basketball like female
basketball players i've ever seen yeah
yeah really good no offense to the men's
team either but if she
it if she went up against
one of the guards she would
i think she would dominate him just
because of her
her height i think
it wouldn't exactly
matter faster
not necessarily not necessarily but i've
beaten a few men in my day
pretty quick pro athletes though mm-hmm
yeah
fleet stuff what the women's are also
pro athletes they're pretty athletic as
well i would i would stop for money i
would do a youtube video on this
if they'd be down i don't know if she
threw a full list of tests
but okay so
do you
would you so we sort of agree that this
isn't fair yeah this is we're in the
same which is interesting because i
didn't think that was your stance wow
because when we talked about it last
time yeah it was just
it was that making some good points
you can say it you can say it i saw i
saw this and i thought about what you
said last time about how like if you
work your whole life with something it's
just like man like i i would cry i don't
care if i got second place i would cry
like yo i've worked so hard did all the
training for this i don't even know
when she started training for this
i honestly wonder if
and i'm not discrediting her but i i
honestly wonder if she didn't
how hard she trained for it to be able
to do it because
essentially she wouldn't have to train
that hard at all to be able to demolish
a record and come in
essentially it's michael michael phelps
the wingspan that
leah has is michael phelps swimming out
there and it's like you can't
you have five six inches of somebody and
your wingspan is just as long as your
height
it's like there's there's nothing you
can change about that that's something
that physically
you can't inject growth hormones in your
body the night before you find out that
you're swimming against this person
and try to be able to make it a level
playing field in a even playing field
and it sucks because
the there's people who are
trans women that are able to play but
then you have women who are born
biologically a woman they just
were gifted with more testosterone than
regular women that aren't able to
compete in their sport that they
are
biologically a woman in i wonder because
you you showed me there was the case um
guys and if you know more information on
this put it in the chat but
um i know there was a case where you
said this girl was supposed to compete
and she couldn't because she naturally
had high
testosterone i was wondering
because what i've found is a lot of
stuff like this there's like more to it
mm-hmm if you take steroids to use your
testosterone go higher oh apparently it
does so i was wondering if maybe they
thought she was on steroids because of
how high her testosterone was
and so how and i know a lot of pro
athletes like do drugs like a lot like
that's like i know a lot of people that
just compete at the high level of like
power lifting and they do it so i can't
even imagine like yeah but i have a i
have a family member who has a
naturally
a lot of testosterone and so
it's not an athlete at all or anything i
could just be like
yeah yes
so i wonder how they like determine is
it just like is there a cut off or
something
that's hard because if there's a cut off
then how are trans women able to compete
yeah i don't know yeah
if she wasn't taking
steroids why did she get like
why was she not allowed to compete
that's why just because her testosterone
well that's but that's that's
but that's that's what i'm asking like
what i've found with stuff like this is
there's usually like more to it but they
never i remember when this happened and
i was like well why isn't she able to
compete yeah they never said anything
about steroids like she took steroids so
that's why she's not competing it was
literally just because her testosterone
level
was higher than um the
regular
i don't know i mean i just think it
should be biological woman biological
like whatever you were born as we should
just compete like i
would you guys support if there was a
lot like next year they're like this is
ridiculous and they said we're banning
no trans women can compete in the
women's division would you support that
i
deep down i'm like yeah because
you know we're women we want to compete
with yeah
and i want to work hard
and compete against women and yeah i'm
paying against women and know that i'm
not like at a deficit and i'm trying i'm
not competing i'm doing all this but
because i am not as good as this person
is not because this person is
physiologically environmental
biologically like stronger and in
physicality
like i'd rather it be a fair playing
field
my skill level is not up to your skill
yeah yeah so
why do you guys hesitate because it's
like
a part of it is unfair because it's like
we're we're in a society now where
people are allowed to be at to identify
us whoever they want to be so it's kind
of hard to say like yeah you're allowed
to be a woman but you're not allowed to
take part in women's spirit
what if i said i identify as a teenager
and started blowing high school kids out
of the water
that
is subject
yeah so shouldn't it just be like what
it is
like you can identify what you want in
your personal life but don't you think
from like a policy perspective it should
just be like what it is
because my thing is like if we can't
even advocate for ourselves how do we
expect men to advocate for us if we
can't even advocate for ourselves
it's it's hard because you also want to
be inclusive be inclusive and be
respectful respectful those decisions
yeah of their choice but
i would tell that to a trans person i
literally i would say and i would say it
in a nice way like look i don't want to
get my ass beat by y'all yeah because
yeah i don't want to i'd rather league
or like the playoff finals yeah
um i'm versus like a trans woman yeah
like that i'll be pissed off yeah
because essentially like skill level
could be neck at night but you're always
going to have a leg up on somebody
because you used to be a man i like
women didn't have that opportunity to go
be a man for a second to get all the
physicality of a man and then be able to
go back to women's force and i'm not
saying that that's what they're doing
but it's like that's what that's what as
women like you're missing the only way
we can get that is if we start taking
testosterone and we start taking things
that
give us that leg up mm-hmm so yeah
i'm gonna read super chats really quick
guys we got a decent amount guys okay
just so you guys know
all super chats are being reinvested
into the platform you're gonna see some
updates soon i got a really big donation
for the channel you're gonna see um
multiple cameras we're getting more mics
coming in i get paid um
on the first of april so all donations
that you guys put in i'm gonna get the
money at the end of the month so
um
that's when you can expect the like
updates so send money um because what i
would like to do is get a new table as
well that's my new thing that i'm buying
okay so um zentian's 50 super chat
you are my favorite oh my gosh then
teens you always be sending like money
money
thanks to feminism we now have eroded
barriers that protected previous genders
in the name of exclusivity the real
question is where does the left put new
boundaries because if you stand for
nothing you will fall for anything
you guys think that
what does it mean by left leg so they're
basically saying if we can't even stand
up if we say like sort of
they're saying the left no no they mean
the left like like all right yeah okay
okay so they're saying like if we can't
stand up and say like that's a man
that's a woman then like and say that
policy is wrong like how are we gonna
like protect ourselves that is true
that's true because if we don't
essentially if we don't say like trans
women can't compete we're
we're putting ourselves
in
kind of in danger because
in sports especially in a contact sport
if you're going up against somebody and
say like say we're post and we're going
up against a trans woman we're we're
about to get bodied and it could
seriously injure us
because
as even as a guard say you're driving
you're driving uh down the lane and
someone just bumps you a little bit it
can send you flying and i've like
like a
career and an injury yeah and i've had
friends who've competed against trans
women i've competed against trans women
and they've told me that
yeah this person came down the lane and
they just bumped me just a little bit
and it sent them like a flying and it's
just
you're putting like essentially this is
a dangerous situation yeah and so but
it's like
it's like you guys are both so logical
like you know this so i feel like we
should be like
like it shouldn't even when i ask you
like would you stand for that policy
like there should be no hesitation and i
and i but i understand because i think
as women we have this like empathy
yeah we want to include people we want
to
and it's like natural times and i have
that too but
i just i
oh my god it just makes me really mad
yeah
because i just think of myself like i've
worked so hard to get to this point
so hard like i i've put in god knows how
many hours to get as good as i am
exactly and i can maybe go to europe and
get free housing and a couple hundred
bucks a month yeah
and i want to share that with men yeah
or go to a [ __ ] country and make decent
money but i'll be on an island with more
goats than people like what do i have
for my money
it might even become harder like to get
like opportunities in the future if what
if in the future oh goodness like our
leagues are filled by chances and they
just take it
see that's that's that's where like
but that's what i feel like like yeah
because we yeah because we keep letting
it go and i think that's what like
that's what we did
eight years ago
instead of saying like why the hell is
caitlyn jenner getting a female award
remember she got the the courage award
like the female courage award
yeah i'm like why the hell is she taking
away like someone else's award
like you're telling me caitlyn jet like
come on like
let's just pull up a picture
wait kate when and so essentially
all the accolades that caitlyn jenner
had
before
when she was a man
do those go away now like there's no
more chris no chris she still has like
the record books or whatever but
that's not that's not her anymore
i don't know
i think it's it's still like bruce has
like bruce lee yeah if like a man that's
transitioned was previously a gold
medalist in the men's like 100 meter
yeah and they transitioned to a woman is
that still his title or does that get
passed down like
oh i don't
i don't know but like
if me i would just live in reality and
say you can dress up as a girl but you
won't actually be a girl yeah you can be
a trans woman that's why if i say like i
say trans woman because you can't carry
children yeah you can't like you don't
have to go through pain
once a month
every moment every month
you don't have to
that's that's like the one thing that
does upset me is it so easy for
i'm not saying it's easy for them to
transition but it's easy for people to
say oh you're a woman
and
it's just like there's
there's so much that comes with being a
woman and it's not just to say that
women are just this just that but that
comes with being a woman and there's no
going around and there's no if ands or
buts about it and
people can come in and transition and
they can choose to be a woman i wish i
could choose not to have a period of
money i could choose not to
have just the womanly things that happen
to us that our heart i wish i could
choose to not have to operate and pain a
lot throughout the day and
it's just that's like the irritating
thing about it yes i want to be
respectful of their choice respectful of
how they see themselves and how they
live their lives but it's just like
it's hard it's like so there's this
this is not about um
uh trans people there's this person who
born white
they
are they talking about rachel doll i
don't remember her name but she got tan
tan tan tan
and she's like
i'm black i identify as a black person
it's just like wait how how
you were
you are not born and she went to africa
and got blessed and
everything and
is not is not that
there's another she's um
she's from over on this side yeah the
world
but it's like
it's kind of
there's a lot of things that yeah like
you can't just be like yeah one day and
be like okay
i'm a black person yeah what if i woke
up instead of instead of the whitest
girl on earth i'm now the blackest girl
like a pearl i would be like you know
what girl
don't
that's what i'm saying like you'd be
disrespectful because there's struggles
like black people go through that i
don't yeah and me like claiming like
getting tan one day like yeah painting
my skin like it's the same thing that
they're doing
but why is like i don't understand why
is that acceptable but like one is
acceptable and what is it that is true
yeah i think it's just the way that
society is now though
they're trying to normalize a lot of
things and they're trying to normalize
like
like trans women trans men like yeah and
where where like nowadays we can't even
speak some and say like she or she's
like
yeah i mean
i mean i'm still cool
yeah like unless they get offended
whatever but it's like sometimes
nowadays you have to be aware full of
stuff like that yeah that's how society
is that site is starting to construct
this way for us to think yeah we have to
be whip like yeah wary of things like
that that's why
yeah that's why it's hard to just say
like no she can't compete you know i
mean yeah
it's like almost like we're pro like i
don't think it's natural because i like
i feel like a lot of people like
listening to me because i'm like no
that's not real
and it's kind of like like a lot of
times when i say something like like i
feel like people are like programmed to
be like politically correct you don't
want to offend anyone i will say that
it's true yeah
you don't you're like this is it and
this is it i remember the first time
that i came on the podcast with you i
was like i was like oh are you pouring
it
i felt a little bit no no no but it was
good now like i i understand
where you come from and why it is that
you you think the way you do and that's
that's perfectly fine um
it's just i feel like
there's certain things in society
that
we have made like
touchy subjects it's like
don't we cannot talk about this because
it's
you don't wanna you don't wanna say the
wrong thing and it's just like but what
if i'm just expressing my opinion can is
my opinion wrong if it's not agreeable
to yours and i think that's
when it comes to when it comes to that
side of the
lgbtq
plus community
i think that that's one of the touchy
places and correct me if i'm wrong on
that because i don't i don't claim to be
the network of all of that
so yeah well it's almost like there's
certain even like race like is a touchy
subject too
yeah like there's just certain subjects
and i think it's like lgpt
lg
the lg you know yeah
like like right like there's just
certain subjects that i feel like people
can't speak freely about because they
don't want to like be canceled or like
say the wrong thing yeah and i feel like
if
if it wasn't like that so many so much
more so many more people would be
educated on
other people's
lives and how they operate and be able
to express themselves and if they don't
agree they don't agree and
we were going to have their opinions
it's just
you want to be if you're not if you're
not on the right side you're not
respectful
and
it's just like why
why yeah
because there is it's like my opinion is
my opinion and when i say my opinion is
not to be disrespectful but that's just
you know what that's how it is you know
it's all so crazy i feel like
i think um
it's unfortunate because i think most
people don't have really strong opinions
either way
yeah you know what i mean i think most
people are kind of in the middle
but it's almost like in order to stop
stuff like this you have to be loud like
if i'm not in the u.s right now but if i
was like there are very few things i
would protest for one yeah bring back
plastic straws that would be my first
protest
i would i would march the streets
but this is like the second thing
because i just
i have never been like so much in an
athlete's like shoot like because i can
like i can just feel yeah how that would
feel like like
if i was sitting behind someone that was
trans oh my i oh i would be so mad
i can't even imagine i don't know if i
would have competed
honestly i don't know if i would have
been yeah they should have protested
everyone should have sat out if they was
well i don't know if they're really
against it though they haven't really
spoken out i feel like that they have to
be there's no way no
i mean they they probably are
upset about it but they haven't spoken
out how many events did she do was it
just the one
event i don't know i can look forward
you guys know how many events she's
essentially if she's a well-trained
swimmer
she can swim in all the events and just
win them all
let me see leah thomas
um
[Music]
i don't even know you guys know how many
events i think she only did one i'm
going to read super chats real quick
you're going crazy right now i want you
to create a jingle for super chat so let
me say super chat just push the board
and go soup
actually guys i need to learn to use the
sound board soon i'm going to press one
i have no idea what button that was but
i found that he probably was like
okay okay um five dollars from anderlin
plays games if we keep going down this
road there will be no woman sports
besides gymnastics transitioning men
won't do well in female gymnastics
that's true
i'm really happy some of them be
it's probably technical stuff it
probably comes down to like technical
stuff not the person to ask
i don't know
it requires a lot of like
well men are flexible but it's just
because like more yeah
yeah yeah
from i don't know nothing about but
that's
that's
it's it's actually a very good point but
yeah
yeah it's actually because i did say
like yeah what if in the future like our
sports is run by
trends like there's more trans women
than biological women
i was just like then there wouldn't be
any women supporting
men and trans women sports
that is such a good point
that's like a stupid good point yeah
because like
because that's what i always think of
like from a policy perspective you have
to think of the extreme like even with
the bathrooms right yeah what's the
extreme of that
[ __ ]
oh no what's the extreme of like letting
trans men into the women's bathroom
[Music]
yeah the extreme
the extreme is predators yeah yeah
that's because you always like when i
think of a policy perspective like like
there's so many people you have to think
of the extreme
and this like now because they didn't
stop it eight years ago when caitlyn
jenner like took that title that she
shouldn't have had
now now we see the extreme
and it's like almost like vote culture
or whatever like they didn't stop it
early i wonder who else was in the
running for that um
that award what we can google it and
what else caitlyn
they did to
or like they could have a cree uh
like a courageous trans woman award yeah
like like we're not we're not like
excluding
yeah it's just it's just that like
there there is if there wasn't no
difference then
there wouldn't be men and women we would
just all
play together actually why don't we just
look at who got the espy award in 2022
oh
it's called the sb i've never really
heard of it and i didn't care back then
but i just think of now is like we see
the repercussions
um women's tennis
um kyle murray
paige oh uconn basketball you know what
that is oh is that um i don't know i
don't think i know that i don't know how
it works i'm gonna be honest but you
guys get what i'm saying like it's
almost like if we don't stop it early
like the the extremes happen yeah okay
wait let me keep reading um
two dollar super trap from the water the
trans dude blew the woman right off of
me
oh the water
you get it
the water the water super chatted two
dollars and said the trans women blew
the women right on
doug mpa 2010 no men i know or no men i
know are down with trans women competing
against biological women the majority of
us men don't want this why are women
giving away their
sport so true
why why
why do women do that like we
you guys are doing it now
i'm trying to figure it out
like
yeah
but it's like we were saying earlier
it's like that empathy and we don't and
we don't want to be the person to speak
up yeah because it's not it's not like i
don't think it's natural to women to
like go into conflict like i think men
are better at it
yeah it's like we're saying like
we
dang
person made a good point
and like essentially like if it keeps
going if we keep making this exception
there's going to be
more and more trans women athletes that
are going to come out and play the
sports and it's going to be more and
more to where there's less and less
biological women that have those
opportunities to play and scholarships
going to be taken um
spots on pro teams are going to be taken
because i mean
naturally to the natural eye if you look
on a piece of paper you don't know if a
person is a trans woman or a biological
man you see this skill sales skill set
blah blah blah and then you see oh
they're six six and you have a 511
person and the skill set is the same i'm
gonna pick the sixth sixth person and
then you find out as a trans woman
you're just like
okay well they're six six so it's okay
it's like
there's going
there
will come a point where it's just
we won't have a shot anymore
and there's nothing
physically nothing we can do about it to
train ourselves to be able to
compete with men yeah
yeah and it's like and that's so sad
like that makes my like i love
people people think i don't because i
say men are better than women but i love
women's sports like i i don't think i
would be who and where i am today if i
didn't have sports exactly like i would
even go as far as to say like it like
saved me out of like rough situation and
i think a lot of athletes would like say
that
and like the thought of just having like
these guys like
like dressed as women kicking our asses
yeah it would
it would suck but like
like
i think they they like people should
really consider like
making another
another
another league or just like yeah another
league
and it'd just be
the trans league and
that's the fairest
way
like as we've stated
biologically you're still
a man underneath like you can identify
as a woman we'll all identify like we'll
all say you are a woman yeah
like you're still going to be better
than us physically like physically so
it's only fair for them to have their
own league if they want to be identified
as a woman yeah
and essentially
i don't know how
like
money works with schools and where they
get it from but i i would think that
you'd be able to get more money if you
have
trans athletes because you would want to
schools may want to promote that more
it's schools love promoting the best
things out there and so you'd be able to
get more grants from people who
maybe are trans
men or women that they don't know you're
donating and
i think it it'd be something to consider
no i would agree actually i would be
fine with a third league or even a
league where like men and women can
compete against each other if they want
to
but it's also back to like we i think
you said this on one episode where
a lot of like you don't know that
they're trans going in
and so there was a fighter that did this
and this fighter was just kicking
women's ass and then it came out that
they were trans i don't know i i can't
say the name i don't even know real
people's names
i'm not gonna know it
yeah and i'd be cool with the trans
olympics but
i just oh my gosh
okay next next 50 sentients you are my
dude you are my dude
what do you do what do you do for a
living because you kill it
um i find
i find the guest's idea of being
respectful disingenuous i am direct and
offend people with my morals and beliefs
that doesn't mean i'm being
disrespectful having an ethical
foundation and stand on it don't let
others dissuade you so easily
it's true that's true it's they don't
understand what it's like to be a girl
no
it's easy it's easier to
be more vocal about stuff and be able to
express your opinion when you've had
that opportunity to do it your whole
life and you've been in situations where
you've been able to express yourself and
not have
certain repercussions happen to you and
it's like it's hard to
start doing that or try to do that when
it's been something that you haven't
been able to do our society
really says you shouldn't shouldn't do
no i mean we didn't like grow up like
that yeah and that's why i think the
older generation they didn't grow up
with social media mm-hmm so they're like
why don't you just say your opinions
yeah we're like i've seen every
influencer get cancelled since 2010
for saying the wrong thing like cancel
culture is so big it's like what is the
wrong thing is the wrong thing something
that you don't agree with so that makes
it wrong
and so all these other people that agree
with me are wrong as well this is what
i've noticed actually
the cl whenever i see a clip and i get
kind of like offended by it
it's because the shoe fits a little bit
yeah
and what i've noticed is that the more
like like the angrier someone gets it's
because the shoe fits mm-hmm
and
yeah that's that's what i've i've
noticed like there is some cases where
cancer culture hack has has been good
because it's like pedophiles i'll give
them
we can cancel pedophiles um one with
the
case that happened in the summer um some
guy that was gonna be like a record
label guy he his girlfriend like posted
videos of her him abusing her and um he
was about to like get a big record label
deal and she posted it like just before
he was about to do that and like there
was videos of her like screaming and
crying and everyone's like
oh do you think do you think that's okay
to cancel him without going to court i
feel like because because you have no
idea if she was hitting hitting him
first a lot of people yeah like because
it's like the timing was a bit
like
yeah yeah yeah time's a bit crazy but
then at the same time if it is true that
he
like if he's gone to court and he
actually was like
beating her and stuff it's like
he doesn't well who i might say he
doesn't deserve what he's worked hard
for but i just feel like
that's the consequences of the actions
that you've done well i think it's i
think it's cool like to cancel someone
if they're found guilty but a lot of
times like the media becomes public
opinion yeah and it's like the court the
court of public opinion isn't always
correct
and the media can
as well
what sometimes that's the court of law
as well no that's true whatever the
court thinks is true if it's
but but the problem is in the u.s it's
like it's pretty hard to convict someone
of something like it's like because the
u.s
it's
it's innocent no no you are okay
no you're right that's true there's like
money like someone gets a good lawyer
they can get out of something but like
like i i've like gone to i've like
pressed charges again it's harder than
you think
i'll say something from back in the day
a person's name i was like let me not
say that
um
so i don't know i just think like it's
easier like to post a video and paint
someone as something than it is to
convict someone yeah it's never it's
never gonna be perfect right and
you never know how true and i'm not i'm
not
discrediting the situation but we often
we often
without like
when it comes to
when it comes to
women
there's like a
well like
what happened and i don't know if that
would be vice versa like if it was if
she was going into um
a big record
label and had like a contract or
whatever and she was about to blow up
and he posted a video
uh
would we question like well like why why
now
does that make sense i i think
like we have believe all women
yeah
i don't understand cause there's some
crazy ass [ __ ]
that will purposely that will purposely
and i'm not not saying that that was her
yeah
they will purposely put themselves in
certain positions to ruin
someone's
complete life like um there was
um a boy years ago he
was supposed to be a top prospect for a
college no it was either for a college
or to go pro
and this um girl it wasn't the one that
we talked about that one time but this
girl
said that um
she he like
i don't know what the word is that woman
rape grape there you go raped her and
his dreams were shattered and then years
later it comes to find out that it
wasn't even him or the situation didn't
even happen and it's like
how do we how do we get to that
what wouldn't why why do we just believe
hearsay she's
like
why and that's but that's even like what
we do with videos because you have no
idea what happened before like she could
have hit him over the head with a chair
before the video and then he freaked out
yeah
personally
if i was a man and someone hit me over
the channel who you are i'm knocking you
i'm rocking you across the face
but i think like i don't know we i think
women and men have this like innate
instinct to like protect women a little
bit yeah because even when i post [ __ ]
on tick tock if i'm going in on like a
girl like like bill even if she's wrong
and i think again i feel it too because
sometimes when i'm like
i'm going at someone it's like really
hard for me because i'm like i'm sorry
yeah i'm sorry and they could be wrong i
like apologized to people after like i'm
look i'm sorry it's just part of the
show
i meant what i said but i'm sorry yeah
it's hard it's hard as
as hard as women that's why when we were
um
i can't remember his name he was here
that one time i won't know it oh you you
know his name um the guy next was he
sitting next to purple sarah
yeah like he was here and he was asking
if we tell our friends like you look fat
or like nah you don't look good in that
it's like we
we
don't say it like see it like that yeah
there's a situation
um that some of my friends were telling
me about that happened
and one of our friends
she she didn't smell too good and i
don't even know if they said anything to
her and it was just like oh y'all just
gonna let her walk around smelling like
that and i'm like did anybody say
anything and it's just hard because it's
like
when something's wrong
we want to
not hurt somebody by not telling them
but you not saying something is just as
wrong
i think i think women like naturally we
want to say what makes people feel good
rather than what is like true yeah
and i and i think like thanks
i don't need to but i do sugarcoat a lot
of things yeah no i do that's like why
um i mean that's why people watch me is
because they're not used to and i think
i say it most of the time pretty nice
and like not even like you should see
some of the other podcasts that do
similar like they are not they're like
stop wifi
when i'm like look at these studies i
mean if you like
and i feel like men don't understand
that's what i'm saying because men can
just
do it because they've that's
that's how it's been for them they can
just do it and then not come off
a certain way unless they
say it a certain way we could be like oh
my gosh like wow like yeah armani i just
want to let you know something like this
is this this and i could say with the
sweetest voice and it could offend it
could offend her just because i can't i
said something bad about her but unless
like we think of each other as enemies
sometimes as well women like you could
be you could be saying it in the nicest
way but in my head i'm like this girl
does not like me do you know what i mean
yeah yeah instantly like was like
because it's a woman saying it to me um
like she doesn't like me yeah like she
thinks something you know i mean yep
yeah
well and i think like i think that's
women's super power right like i think
like being like more emotional and
empathetic like that's our superpower i
just think we've gotten to a place in
society where it's too far
like i think being able to say something
in a kind way to someone that's not a
negative thing yeah it's just negative
when we can't
like express it when we're letting men
in the women's division because we want
to be nice yeah yeah and they're beating
our ass
now that we come full circle yes
96 oh we got to over 100 live viewers
guys this is the most viewers i've ever
had on a show
i'm going to read some more super chats
guys if you have any comments or
thoughts super chat now because i'm i'm
reading sorry these are a ton today
thank you five dollar super chat from a
loser
i'm sorry guys i can't i can't read
these elazia e life thank you for the
sticker five pounds twenty dollars from
zentians that's just the way society is
now it's not about trying to construct a
way for us to think how about not
conforming to society and having your
own thoughts women's voices are louder
by far than men's now how about using
them what do you think i'm doing but
thank you thank you but thank you for
the super chat
thank you for the super chat daddy
thank you thank you for chatting
[Laughter]
exactly
yeah this is the point in case
that's what i'm doing sorry but i think
but like i will say i think it's
something that has to be like
like deprogrammed because we're just
like surrounded by it all like we've had
the same media like conditioning since
we were kids
and it's not
it's not necessarily taught to like
luckily i had very
my dad doesn't watch social media so i
had a very grounded dad and i think
that's why i'm like logical and able to
like think the way i do but even me in
college i was like i hate men
sorry guys i had my moments
i think every female has that moment
we're like
men
we get hurt by one
okay next pearl just stopping by to show
some more love i'm heading out no
not you sentiences
come on baby stay
they follow the shot but i'm happy to
come back and and call out bs from all
the sheeple who only echo society spill
be well and get that studio upgrade
thank you
daddy
am i considering getting headphones for
the show yeah with more donations like
this i will um
okay let's see sandra remember for two
months men and women's have been
separate
bathrooms not for men's safety
um
also guys also um you should become a
member because when i get to enough
members i'm going to start doing like
events in cities and i want to do like
matchmaking and it's going to be fun
yeah it's going to be it's going to be
like a yeah yeah i'm not close to near
enough to like put the time into it but
it's coming so you guys show me the
demand i'll do it um sandra again men
are stronger and more capable women
bring people into the world different
job with equal value we need to work
together i agree
um two dollars from some femi female
behinds
were getting kicked by fake girls
oh
some female behinds are getting kicked
by fake girl
oh
i swear this is the same person twenty
dollars from willie thomas they're 20
pounds from william thomas thank you
sentience oh you stayed zen
thank you
and so sentience is like he sent more
super chats than anybody but i but i see
all of you i see don't don't feel like
you can't be a part of it
stop blaming society for individuals
ability
to take accountability for their own
actions if you don't agree with
something
say something against its um
i didn't know what that meant have a
spine and to answer
and to answer your question pearl
i'm in medicine
clearly oh
straight women have a responsibility to
stand up for what is right sometimes
being a woman with a disagreeable
personality is a good thing in cases
like this for a woman you learn to pick
your battles i'm actually like very
agreeable this is something learned it's
not natural to me like sometimes guys i
have a really hard time with it but i've
just learned it because i like to debate
people um sandra again sandra you said
you're coming through yeah
show these men you got the bread yeah
i can go people oh yeah
um however much time a man is a man in
false rape allegations should get the
same time behind bars that woman that
lied should get the same time i think
she should get double the time
okay read that again like so she's
saying if if i
accuse someone of grape
and
he gets four years behind bars she's
saying that like she should get the same
amount of time he got behind bars and
i'm like she should get double or triple
if you lie about grape oh
yeah if you lie about it i think that
that's worse yeah then yeah then
like
you're essentially saying that this
person
did this that's already a horrendous act
and you're putting them in a situation
that if it wasn't for you lying on them
they wouldn't have been there like both
both situations are horrible dude lying
on someone and saying something that
didn't happen that's
just as bad as it actually happening
yeah she never got if he if she never
got caught out sorry if she never got
out i'm just putting it up
you know there's so many like
that like things that he'd have to go
through throughout life like being put
on a sex offenders
his jobs like he won't be able to work
in the future yeah there's certain jobs
he can't work here yeah like that that's
not just destroying the four years that
he's in bar like bars it's also
destroying his future as well yeah yeah
she does deserve more time if she does
like yeah
because i've got so many brothers i'm
like if anyone oh
yeah i would i've got 13 brothers i'm
like yeah if anyone does that to one of
my brothers i'm like oh go crazy i'm
crazy i would probably do it
i
i have my brother had a girl like an ex
that would be commenting on my tic tocs
and be like he did this this and this
and i was like so irritated because this
is what happened okay she stayed in a
situationship with my brother for over a
year
that was your choice honey he didn't
like you like that he let you know so
many times he didn't want to date you
he's a dude i'm i'm sorry looking mm-hmm
if if he let her know he let her know so
many times and then she's caused the
audacity when it doesn't go well
mm-hmm yeah so come on my tic-tacs like
i i was not oh my god i was so mad
like any of
y'all you're not involved in that it's
not yeah exactly exactly no they
so my brother he like makes girls fall
in love i guess yeah you're like
my brothers are a bit you know yeah
i have a little bit of a whole brother
yeah
yeah okay do you guys think that the
path to hell is paved with good
intentions
i never understood
that that's what i think is happening
because i think the people that are
allowing trans women into the league
they have good intentions like they're
trying to include people
but when but we're just not on the side
of reality yeah because essentially
only down the path of us not being able
to the end of women's sports yeah ends
up like biological women's sports
so essentially
and in this aspect yes yeah yeah
yeah i think in this situation like i
think a lot of like the greatest
atrocities have been
like paved with good intentions
because like you can have a good
intention yeah but
you have to think about the
like the effect yeah the reality of it
yeah because every action has like a
reaction yeah
yeah and it's almost like if we don't
stop stuff like early it just keeps
snowballing yeah snowball effect
yeah
because i wanted to show you guys
there's another one i wanted to show you
dang
the men
look it there's me
on the top
yes
pretty things
and sports are they letting them in the
olympics now
like
i don't
i don't know i haven't i haven't
what was the thing
like one man versus the whole like
like this is nuts
it's a six-year-old dude annihilating
wow
it's humbling isn't it a little bit
i heard
like a 15 year old team beat a wnba team
i don't know if i'm like making that up
but
like or like
18 maybe like a high school team
like i believe some of these high
schoolers be huge
they do they do and like now is i don't
know if they changed it back
but now as you have to do
one year of college
and essentially you can go into the
league i think that's how it is now oh
really i think so because usually not
usually but it used to be you didn't
even have to do college period and you
um you can go straight to the league i
think
lebron did it
and kobe those are two that i can think
of i know there's probably more
um
but yeah so but there's some high school
boys i'm like what are they putting in
this food to make y'all look like grown
men
if i play someone on one on one i like
if it's a guy i kind of analyze their
skill where if it's like after they've
played more than two years of high
school they can usually be me
[Music]
interesting
high school is equivalent to
um college here
that's that would be yeah sixth form
would be
our senior year
equivalent to y'all and then it's year
nine year ten and year eleven okay is
high school
how do you guys think we can like like
let's say there's um a trans person that
joined
our team
how do you think we can prevent things
in the future like if this if this
mentality like comes to england and like
like they start letting people in our
leagues here what would you guys do
would you just let it happen or would
you try to do something to change it
i don't know what i would do to be
honest yeah
i um
it's
i will no
no and if it did happen i would say that
there needs to be a limit you can't you
can't put
have a team of 15 and half of those
people are trans women it's just it's
just
not fair like yes we we'd be winning and
everything but personally i probably
wouldn't play i probably wouldn't see
the floor at all but it's like it's kind
of like it's kind of like co-ed teams
when you are um
you're playing uh coed basketball it's
like the girls have to match up with the
girls and guys have to match with the
guys and that's on both ends office and
defense and you can't have
if the female isn't on the floor if like
the male the majority isn't on the floor
yeah but you could still go up for a
layup and then
yeah
that issue is because i feel like now
it's like
it's a swimming it's like a non-contact
sport yeah
contact
as we said before we can have career
ending injuries for them just like doing
something simple simple just um
defending us in the pain like i could
get a career and an injury from that
yeah i would just say no you would say
no but how would you how would you say
now they left they let them in they're
they're happy to get in touch with like
oh so you would actually go to the
administration yeah okay and i would too
yeah
yeah because i'll get in touch with the
governing bodies of the actual
yeah like england basketball or
something yeah yeah i mean is it
it's probably easier to do than the
freaking ncaa oh of course
that's crazy i like i sometimes like
when i hear these arguments
i'm like i don't even understand how
grown adults are like talking like this
like
grown ass like men and women are making
these laws
yeah you know like i'm like how are
adults like grown like letting
young young people and even high
schoolers yeah i saw this thing where it
was like a high school track and they
let men in like compete against the
women and track that's what i said i'm
like how are adults
letting this happen
i'm like cognitively that no it's just
like common sense that
i'm gonna just bring up the swimming
picture one more time because like like
we said earlier if there
if there were it wasn't no difference
first of all you wouldn't need to
specify between men and women just be
people just be people
yeah and
yeah there wouldn't be no separation
between men and women's sports
period if there wasn't
a disadvantage and if their there wasn't
that if there wasn't something that
needed a separation
and
now
there's something that wasn't
popular back in the day when they did
make the
men and women sports that are now coming
into it
and it's like
oh just because you throw
women's behind trans okay yeah go ahead
it's like
but we're forgetting that there's a
separation for a reason and there's a
separate and there's and we have that
separation because of
these things that qualify you as a man
and these things that qualify you as a
woman and if it was equal like men would
join them were women trans oh my gosh
biological women would join the men's
league and kick ass but they don't you
only see that happening one way yeah
and oh my gosh it's just like i i just i
i hear some of these people like talk
that make the laws
that make the law
do you see that do you see that clip
where the girl was like
the girl was like that's a dude it's at
the swim meet and then the guy that
worked at the ncaas was like well are
you a doctor and she's like i'm not a
vet but i know a dog when i see one
wow
she's like i don't need a vet like
yo
[Music]
and that's even when you sent me that
clip where that where that gra guy was
like well you're on hormones for a year
you go through these changes and i'm
like
i don't need a degree to just tell you
this is crazy like this is nonsense that
was the case i can't tell you the
science i have no idea what they do to
their body
but like come on if that was the case
then everybody would just be
born
just be born and we'd just be
born and then you can choose
yeah
you just choose do you want to take
testosterone for the rest of your life
or do you want to take action from the
rest of your life and then once you take
that
that identifies you as a woman that
identifies you as a man and if that if
that is the key factor then what what
would be the point of us having
having boobs having a uterus having the
i don't know if i could say
the other word
the v word
you could just say that
a little kid or cat
there wouldn't be a point
of
any of that
for us to like have those things as a
woman if the deciding factor was
estrogen and testosterone
yeah it's it's having kids yeah that's
what and then they'll use the stupid
argument well some women can't have kids
yes but they still have the biological
things to have kids if this is
yeah and then the other argument they'll
say is like
women like well you're stronger that's
not all men that'll dominate it's like
some men
like like i could still out i can
outlift a lot like i'm strong yeah i'm
like
i can outlift a lot of guys
but my brother who hasn't worked out in
five years can out bench me yeah
and that's just that's just it like
i bet you my little brother that hasn't
lifted weights maybe
more than a month in his life could
probably
out bench me or probably lift weights
more than me just because
he's a man and it's just like
that's like that's like saying like
teenagers versus adults
like because some teenage like let's say
we do a 13 year old division should 13
year olds play against like 21 year olds
because some 13 year olds can compete
with the 21 yeah and that's like that's
the exception there's there's some
some kids that can do that but like you
can't take the exception and then group
everybody in that exception and it's
just like well i'm i'm not that
exceptional i can't play with no 21 year
old like i want to play with people my
age on a level playing field and do you
feel like as a big it's like like
because we're we're both centers right
you're you're kind of centered
like i think
it hurts us more because like i would
have no opportunity at all competing
against i'm not tall yeah
uh trans women yeah i wouldn't have no
like i'm not gonna lie i've played
against guys in like i've played a game
i play against guys like sometimes yeah
and there's just certain things that i
just wouldn't even post up because i'm
like what's the point of posting up
against a guy that's like six foot five
yeah is there really a point he's gonna
block the sh yeah
what's the point so
i talk a lot of [ __ ] to dudes too like i
always tell them
i i always say i can beat them in
one-on-one even if i know i'm damn well
i can't i don't
like completely change the way i play
like i'll shoot a lot because i don't
know i don't want to like get i'm not
trying to yeah yeah
pull up like i shoot more threes than
i've ever shot in my life
and i used to beat my last boyfriend
one-on-one all the time but it was also
because he was really overweight yeah
that was the only reason that like as
soon as it was so humbling because he
lost like a bunch of weight when we were
together and as soon as he like got to a
certain way
i couldn't win anymore no it was just
over with
dang
that's crazy and he he played like what
a year or two of high school bat i
played in college i played overseas like
barely still counts
so for
so for us to be able to
compete with men they have to be
physically
lesser than us
like and like just out of shape for us
to be sure yeah we're shorting
the trans women that are going into
these leagues are actually athletes but
whilst they were a man so like yeah
they're like physically fit already and
then they're going into the league oh
well they're transitioning and then
they're going into our leagues but
they're still like got the
physicality of a man they've been
draining their whole life yeah so it's
like
yeah
and then it becomes dangerous as a
society because we stop like accepting
what reality is yeah then we start like
i i identify as a child put me in pre-k
yeah
like i know i driving a freaking taboo
or the day of my life when these grown
adults are like i identify as a baby
we went like wearing diapers growing
adults wearing diapers and the
it's just it's like you're you're how 40
we're in a diaper
eating baby food drinking out of a
bottle
if you don't look yourself in the mirror
and get yourself get your tail to work
or something you are not an infant
anymore let's bring back bullying
no i swear to god because i feel like
the older generation just bullied each
other out of this [ __ ] they really did
they were you i was bullied it was good
for me i was annoying as hell
sometimes i need to learn to shut the
[ __ ] up
yeah
i can understand that it's just
like all right i could identify as like
native american give me a scholarship
elizabeth
and
they're
like
um
and i feel like it's so touchy now that
people don't go into like looking into
that so you could say that you could say
i'm native american and have all the
information you you need you could have
like i think it's is it 15 you need to
be
native american it's something there's a
certain percentage you need and it's not
you don't have to be full-blooded you
can you just need to be part of a tribe
so in the states there's um uh
in the states there's uh territories in
um
some states and that used to be native
land and so
if you are native american and if you're
from any tribe you can get a scholarship
at certain schools because you are
native american because they're on they
get a lot they get a lot of like native
american scholarships are like
and so um
essentially they
it's like
everybody just takes your word for it i
could say i'm uh
i'm a quarter or 50 cherokee you
wouldn't question it because i know oh
this is where this land is this is where
this is this is i i researched myself
and so i'm able to like convince you
that i'm it like okay
give me my money and i feel like it's
gotten to that to where people just
don't question it they just take their
words and people can
lie
just so easily and it's just like
even even this dude do we think leah
thomas is really trans like
yo i had that thought i had i'm not like
discrediting her but i had that thought
because essentially
essentially it's a cheat code like if
i'm 400 something and immensely and i'm
like nobody's going to question me if
i'm really a transgender no one's going
to ask me for if i'm taking this and i
can be in cahoots with my doctor and say
like if someone asks you if i'm taking
estrogen just say yeah and i'm like i'm
gonna go compete as a woman in the sport
and
dominate and then i'm gonna go to the
olympics make money
for being a trans woman but i'm really
not
and it
is like i don't like she just thinks why
all this looks like a dude like i don't
see fake boobs okay
nothing
it's like a dude in a swimsuit
like like what long hair like what the
i almost think it looks more like a dude
that one
this one
so is that
is that before and after i don't
know
yale trans swimmer beats fellow trans
athlete
i don't i don't i think these are two
different people oh
so this is a yale
transformer and this is
uh
the other one so they're both see
they're both trans and that's that's
fair they're both they're both trans
yeah and
you lost to another trans woman so yeah
like i don't
[Music]
like i just don't even think see how
long
like
i'd be like you know what
oh my god like i
i just okay because i think of all the
people that let this happen yeah the
coach
the coach the administration like
there's so many people that had to let
this happen i'm like
what
this is crazy
i don't i would not want that
i would not want him in my changing room
i'm sorry i wouldn't i would feel weird
it's like
essentially you're telling me the
difference between that those two
pictures so he was on top and yeah he
was on top and about him and essentially
um
the difference between those two
pictures is short hair he was a man lawn
care he's a woman
and i guess his face is a little it's
like not even feminine
like does that look like a girl to you
no
i'm gonna get you guys canceled
this might be the broadcast to do it
there are some there are some women who
have manly features as well yeah that's
what i was gonna say yeah
you know i'm i'm thinking of a couple
and i still think even the girls with
manly features
if
if i if i knew if i was a man
and i was a sketchy one i'm not saying
that she is i was a schedule and i was
an athlete and i'm like okay i'm good
i'm good at men's sports but i'm not
that great if i didn't have
no more conscious
i would do it i'd be like oh i'm
transitioning and dominating women's
sports and then after i do what i need
to do in that and get whatever money i
need to change like i actually want to
de-transition and just go back and be
like
and i'm not saying and like me saying
that i can i can feel like someone's
gonna be like that's disrespectful blah
blah blah just like
if it
if that's if that's all it takes it's
just to take uh i know estrogen i know
taking hormone pills is a lot but if
there's no if i can get in cahoots with
a doctor with people and say hey like
when i make my money i'm gonna pay you
off so if someone comes if a new
reporter asks if they need physical
evidence that i am transitioning to a
woman provide it for them and i got you
i'll pay you off once i get all this
money
and i may i may just have got gave
someone just gold right there
well and and it's like for narcissists
like who would
because i i've talked to tran like trans
people that agree they're like no why on
earth would we be in that league what
what typically yeah no there's like like
blair
wool
i don't know
um
but like
and even caitlyn jenner like she says
that oh no like we should not be allowed
in those leagues
why why is it that like it's like the
like i honestly think a rational trans
person like really would agree and would
understand but like it's like the ones
that have to be the center like i feel
like he wants to be the center of
attention like he knew when he switched
over he would win the league he knew
he'd be the center of attention like i i
don't
i just can't
even assume good intent like i don't
believe he had good intentions
because i don't understand how you can
be next to like this girl
and genuinely look yourself in the
mirror and think that's fair
yeah did you see the picture where
uh she was on the first podium and like
everybody else was on like the third
podium i don't know the story behind it
um
but it was essentially like they were
saying
in my in my opinion that i was like oh
like
we're not even like near this person
and physically and so it's just like
we're just going to automatically be
third because that's how that's how it's
always going to be it's like
we're never going to be first unless
e i don't even know if
if it came to a point where they were
leah is her name leo lisa leah leah
is physically
out of shape to where that sh some uh
biological women be able to beat her
it's like
the wingspan in swimming your your
arm length is
something that is if you got it if you
got long orangutan arms you are going to
dominate and swim because
that's what you use your arms and your
legs yeah and so and then like look at
like this coach right here
how can how can the coach like coach how
does he look like kind of unethical
but the coach could
and the coach could also be benefiting
from this
get a stipend oh you you're one of the
first
coaches to allow trans women to swim wow
we want to give you this we want to give
you that and there's like there's perks
with having i'm not calling her when i
say this i'm not calling her this but
there's perks with having a new shiny
toy or something new like oh attention
is currency yeah like oh new okay let's
publicity news uh news reporters being
on um
news shows being on
podcasts being on whatever and having
people talk about it and people googling
and searching your name the situation
it's like it's generating stuff and
people are gonna to come and talk to you
about the situation so there was
definitely
some perk with that coach allowing that
to happen
i just like this grown ass man like
i just like can't i'm like you get out
there and swim against me
i'm like you have to be a beta ass dude
to allow this like i'm sorry you if as a
man
like i you can i don't know how you can
look yourself in the mirror and train
this grown dude do you think he even
truly respects from women's sport as a
coach though
like he can't yeah yeah even that's a
great question
do you think our coach would allow that
i don't think he would i don't think i
don't think he would i think he'd like
like don't walk away and be like
probably bring him but i'm not not
playing
and have them there for practice player
yeah
we do below on numbers
oh my gosh okay
should i come this week should i come
next week
yo please
so what what if
a coach was like yes i will allow you to
be on the team but only
as a practice player
to because i've practiced against guys
and i've like it's very very helpful to
practice against dudes because
they're just the ones i practiced with
when i was at my second school they were
quick they were shifty and they were it
was it got hard and brought our skill
level up so i could i could understand
like hey like right now
yeah right now like i don't think it's
right for you to play games but
to make to help the team out if you
still want to be on the team and help
the team out you can be a practice
player until things change to where you
are able to play against
people that are just like you and be
safe
um
i think
as long as they still play like because
when we had guys play with us they still
knew they were guys
so they weren't like they don't try to
like kill you yeah they don't try you
know when you play against guys they
don't try hard like i've spoken to i
think i spoke to a friend the other day
and they were like if i'm playing
against a girl if i have a right
i have a body her like
like like 13-0
or like i just let her do what she wants
to do you know it's like they think they
either overplay us all on the players
it's not yeah it's not like a hassle
never level
so
yeah yeah but so like my
thought is like if this person really
thinks they're a girl are they gonna
play at that same like are they going to
be body and girls and possibly injuring
them
and i also like i wouldn't really want a
tran like a trans person in the locker
room i just wouldn't like i wouldn't
feel comfortable with it yeah
like and i say this because some i
probably would but when i think of the
extreme
yeah like when you think because like
from a policy perspective i always think
of the extreme yeah
and like you don't want something that
people because people will abuse like as
we're seeing yeah yeah i'm gonna read
the next super chats
what no i just thought of a movie and of
um
um she's the man
great movie oh yeah yeah yeah that's so
unrealistic
yeah
unless there had to be an ass team
um okay wait let's see that i saw one
from sandra before she came up with 50
super chat but i gotta find it
okay wait um
not a baller i promise the biggest thing
i feel the worst for men about i know a
couple where he spent a thousand dollars
on christmas presents for his
girlfriends she was so ungrateful i
didn't know
the i
and she was so ungrateful i didn't know
that men deal with this kind of behavior
yeah girls i mean they're shitty men and
women like it's just shitty people ten
dollars uh super chat from grover reese
did a stream about this subject last
night and it's excellent to hear
grounded level-headed
level oh my god high-level women
athletes speak on the subject we should
have had you on thp network rocks with
pearly things thank you
invite us invite us your podcast we'll
go on your live stream yeah where are
you at
okay so i'm gonna actually ask you guys
a question i asked you earlier after
this conversation
do
would you say you would have a more a
solid answer when i said like would you
support a policy kicking
trans women out of the women's sports
i wouldn't even say kicking them out
or not allowing them
it shouldn't happen in the first place i
didn't say that like their own league
yeah yeah yeah so they're not excluded
in sports completely yeah but um yeah
having them is like it's is unfair yeah
like where as women we're like having to
like lose out
on opportunities and stuff yeah because
like we're allowing
and that women and that happens that
happens elsewhere as well but it's just
like
in this area we can kind of control it
because
it's like it's awesome yeah
it's art yeah yeah i'll take everything
else
it's been hard to get to this place yeah
it's so hard
like allowing it to be taken away yeah
just like so easily it's just like oh
yeah
it's so like that's what people have i
always say i think women athletes are
the heart hardest working
because we work for like nothing
we work for such a small pot and i don't
really like
i understand like why the pot is small
it's just like not this but it's just
when you love doing this [ __ ] and
there's just no opportunity it's just
like sad because i if i could i would
totally spend
my life like i would totally spend all
of my 20s and 30s playing sports but but
why would i do that for nothing yeah
literally and the opportunity just isn't
there and it's sad i mean it is but for
people better than me
it's a very selective yeah yeah like
some people have that opportunity and
it's just like for the people who
are able to go down that path and have
the opportunity that's great but for the
rest of the people
is they're not going to be able to have
that opportunity it's going to be taken
away because we're allowing
this to happen and it's like i don't i
don't want my family members down the
line to want to my female family members
who want to be able to play
women's sports and they're like you know
what actually all our spots are filled
we have
on a team of 10 let's say we have um
our nine trans women and one biological
woman or just a team full of trans women
just like you know what we can't accept
you anymore because
it's just over
over overpowering women it's just like
we would want to dominate yeah let's do
it mm-hmm
and it would suck
and we almost have to think of like the
next generation
because there's going to be younger and
younger trans people
and i mean like i i played with boys
like before puberty but
but
like
like we have to think about the next
generation like my sister's coming up i
don't want my sisters to play against
yeah it's like not even about or not
even have the opportunity to play yeah
because
of
just allowing
trans women to play and that would suck
i would
oh i would cry
if
i played it played as a young kid
basketball just loved it and i'm like oh
i'mma play in college it's gonna be so
much fun i'm gonna work so hard i'm
gonna get a scholarship and it's just
like um actually you can't play because
there's more trans women now that are
playing and we want them more than you
you're yeah
yeah it's like you're a great player but
physically you don't have what it takes
it's just like
that's something i cannot control and it
would crush me
and like when you know how much sports
has just like changed your life
personally like there's nothing i my
kids will be in sports
i don't care what sport basketball
oh i could
i could think of days where i just said
life wishes crap if i just went out i
just got in the car went out and went to
a park and just shot hoops to clear my
mind i i couldn't imagine where or even
like not even that because i can do that
on my own but just going to practice
having a crap day but going to practice
and being able to see my teammates being
able to just uh do the thing i love and
just being coming out of and be like
okay
all right i can breathe now and not
having that opportunity just to clear my
head i would
i would have been crazy and you make
lifelong friends like some of my best
friends i made through sports
that's true i wouldn't
i wouldn't be where i am in life if i
did not if i did not have sports i think
i would even be in university yeah
yeah
yeah i don't think i would have i would
have i wouldn't have come
yeah yep and it's such a good way for
people from like poorer backgrounds to
like get out of bad situations and go to
like school yeah
yeah it's true
like it it's like um a ticket almost
yeah and just to
because it's just not essentially it's
just not plain
there's so many more aspects like
playing is just one aspect keeps you out
of trouble it keeps you nuts it keeps
you not pregnant
bless the lord
yeah
like teenagers with too much free time
are dangerous yeah and just
that one aspect of playing but there's
so much more that comes with being a
female a biological woman athlete and
for if it keeps going down the road and
for that option
not to for women not to have that option
or the option the pool to be
shrunken down to even smaller than it
already is it would be
devastating and just take away so many
different opportunities from women
completely
like
we would just resort to just being
baby makers and housewives in the end
like an athlete is not on the board
anymore
no yeah i think that makes that's why i
think these conversations are so
important because a lot of times i think
like
if we don't have these conversations
like people are just afraid of like
offending people yeah and like even it
doesn't even have to be like i do it on
camera but like even behind the scenes
like i think these conversations are so
important to have with people
and especially like amongst athletes
because what i've noticed is the people
that are like parading the hardest
for trans women to be allowed into
women's sports they're not athletes like
when i talk to athletes we gen generally
agree because we've generally played
against men yeah and don't want to yeah
no if i had
[Music]
he made my nose bleed and he didn't
realize
like and it's like they don't do it on
purpose
like he pulls put his elbow up and then
like hit my nose i thought i broke it
he's like oh that was a really good
screen sorry sorry yeah
that's just the difference between
playing with men and women
there was one time this memory just came
in my head there was one time i was
playing softball with my um
church
and
i was fast i was quick i was able to get
to the
the um first
first base
quickly
um but i ran into a guy and he was solid
and it knocked the wind out of me now if
i would have ran into a female i
probably would have just blew over
because of my speed but since he's a man
i was like
like it hurt and i was like what the
freak and so it's just
yeah that's just it and when i did co
like i've done co-ed tournaments say
something i was i was like what is that
i heard coat and i was like what oh no
no no
no no no no no
no drugs um when i did when i when i did
co-ed tournaments like there's
volleyball co-ed i swear sometimes if
i'm passing and the guy was hitting i'm
just like don't don't don't hit my face
i don't even care if it hits the floor
yeah because that's a that's a bullet
it's already a bullet when y'all do it
but i can only understand remember
i'd be like one volleyball game if you
guys and i got punched
wait what yeah you guys it was it was
like when before you came down you guys
didn't have any players and then i
played
i don't even know how to play volleyball
and i just helped you guys out and then
i went this year yeah oh was it early
was it early when no one was there okay
i went to the set and then i got punched
in the face i'm not like if a guy did
that would probably be knocked out oh
yeah that hurt so much as well yeah
yeah i can't even imagine
um let me read the final guys if you
have any super chats to send send him
now because i think i'm gonna wrap up
the show um
i i like my favorite part of this
conversation was i feel like you guys in
the beginning were hesitant to say
something and i think at the end you're
like not
would you agree with that yeah i would
agree with that um and i think it's just
important because i think we like yeah i
think i think it's something that's like
programmed in us and it's really hard i
i really the men that watch us don't
understand it but and i think that as we
talked we realized it like personally
like if this happened to us how would it
how would it impact yeah because
i'd be angry yeah comments are making
good like i never even thought of like
that would be the end of women's sports
yeah i didn't even think of that
and
oh
i know i don't even like thinking about
it it makes me and just thinking about
it makes me like just
sad because
i just yeah yeah
um okay wait so the next super chat
um marcel 20 ladies continue to have
these conversations these are tough
conversations that go against the norm
especially if we're looking for more
better
and fair outcomes i agree thank you um
do you guys have any final thoughts
either about the conversation or any
plugs
um
no i you know i genuinely
like conversations like this even though
they're hard
but
just to understand like what everybody's
saying and the
just everything across the board and
trying to
make it like hit home more so i i didn't
like the conversations but what do you
mean by plugs
like like you're on your youtube
instagram
i don't know any plugs that give you
what type of clothes plugs
i don't get can you explain in great
detail are you on like mic clothes i
don't know i don't know how to do this
oh that's a
i could like a hair plug
um no
what type of
there's different sets of plugs that was
like what type of plug you want pearl
i don't know people but i know people
know people
um but no
on um
instagram it's it's your girl
jessiitz.yah.girl
underscore just on youtube it's just
it's your girl jess with the
uh
seven s's at the end
wow yeah someone someone said coke and
plugs
is that what you thought
i'm sorry
i hear things my brain's like whoa
my brain reacts before it's supposed to
um
take her message i don't really have any
like i feel like we covered a lot
throughout the
topic and you guys kind of saw my
opinion and saw my point of view um and
my plugs is uh money on the school xox
on tech talk and instagram oh yes
okay guys if you want to support the
channel um super chats are always
appreciated and i guys you guys raised
so much money like i i don't know how
much it was but this is one of the most
like profitable
um shows that i've done and i'm really
excited to show you guys the upgrade
that's gonna happen at the end of the
month like you're gonna see
well
okay we're gonna buy it at the end of
the month
so maybe maybe maybe like a week or two
after that
the next month come back next yeah
yeah next month like it's going to be
really cool like i got a sizable
donation it's going to be a really cool
studio and i'm so excited to show you
um on top of that if you want to support
the channel another way you can support
is the meal plan okay guys i promise you
this meal plan will change your life
it's food you actually like i've been
trying to lose weight for like four or
five years i couldn't do it like
unsuccessful i tried every diet known to
man this meal plan works and you don't
hate your life and like you can be slim
thick and you feel great that's the
biggest difference is i feel so much
better i have so much more energy so
that link is in the description and
the show gets a pr a portion of that so
you should do that
um
yeah and and and sorry not done yet
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
as you guys know if you have watched
three or more of my lives and you don't
subscribe we have beef okay be like this
is not cool you cannot be watching these
lives and not subscribing like support
the channel help a girl out